je suis très content pour lui par vous
parler d'un sujet qui m'intéresse parce
que justement est quelque chose qui
m'intéresse absolument
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon
corps au broc m'a contacté mais en tient
monsieur greuet ce que tu voudrais bien
parler notre nouvel aspirateur
le robot rock s6 j'ai dit tout de suite
oui pourquoi parce que je déteste faire
ménage pour moi c'est une perte de temps
sèche et en l'aspirateur n'en parlons
pas du coup si vous trouvez des
solutions et si je peux en plus vous
aider vous avoir des solutions des
bonnes pistes et puis surtout utilisé un
produit qui va vraiment vous serez sûr
dé la vie je saute sur l'occasion et
justement pas on parle aujourd'hui cette
chasse et c'est à illéla le robot rock
le s6 le s6 c'est le tout nouveau robot
aspirateur de robot rock c'est une vidéo
qui est réalisé en partenariat avec
robot rock et je vous présente cette
petite bête là alors il ya quelques
temps cette petite bête ya quelques
temps j'ai présenté un le s5 qui était
déjà un excellent produit qu'ils aient
plein de choses alors première chose qui
fait rassurez vous c'est de passer
l'aspirateur et de l'avs et il le fait
bien il le fait seul ace est très
pratique et du couple avec ces petites
bêtes ça va encore plus loin et sabu
solutionne encore plus la vie et ça pour
moi croyez moi c'est vraiment très
important
[Musique]
avec le fc istres au broc nous propose
un robot aspirateur que son président
sera forcément hyper sexy mais nous
propose un joli petit robot aspirateur
qui est plus rapide qui est plus
silencieux qui est plus intelligent qui
fera plus de choses je lis fera beaucoup
mieux surtout alors déjà très simple
c'est très bien avec les 6 500 volts
fini les tâches ménagères fini les
corvées ne vous embêtez nous que du
temps à faire des vidéos être bien ça
c'est vraiment cool
[Musique]
comment ça c'est très très facile votre
petit robot il est sur des routes ça
vous en douterez c'est très simple et
votre petit robot il a plein de capteurs
ya des petits capteurs leila des petits
capteurs là des petits capteurs là des
petits capteurs des petits capteurs
il a plein de capteurs votre petit robot
il est sur sa base sans sa base de
recharge vous avez une application je
vous la montrer dans quelques instants
vous lancez votre robot et lui et quitte
la base et c'est parti pour la grande
aventure qu'est ce qui fait votre petit
rebond il a un scanner qui est situé
juste là et il va tourner tous les côtés
avec ce scanner il à pouvoir connaître
le relief de votre pièce qui va savoir
où sont les murs où sont les ouvertures
qu'est ce qu'il a à faire
ou est-ce qui va aller qu est-ce qui va
contourner en plus il est plutôt
intelligent il se géolocalise ce qui
fait que il dessine une carte de votre
maison vous allez voir dessiner en temps
réel directement de votre application
et lui il garde sans mémoire ils se
baladent et y trace des grands traits
des grandes lignes ça correspond en
réalité à tous les endroits où il est
déjà passé il va passer partout partout
où il le pourra partout où ils pourront
plus tard il passe sous les petits
meubles
il peut passer sous les sommiers ça
dépend de votre chambre il a passé entre
les meubles partout où il pourra aller
il ira et il le fait vachement bien et
même dans les angles parce qu'en fait
ils avancent tac et la ronce tac tac tac
et en fait ça vous avez une espèce de
petit connecteur ici et là et dès qu'il
ya touché up
il sait qu'il y côtoie mur ou comprend
d'objets idée qu à lire paris quand on
est comme avec le laser il va où il va
et bien c'est vachement bien fait c'est
vachement pratique et c'est très
intelligent alors notre petit robot il a
le truc qui va super cool qui se situe
juste là vous avez alors il faut que les
vides
votre petit bac à poussière voilà je les
retire et le mien il est plein forget de
le vide il ya toutes les cochonneries
elles sont là j'ai ensuite une petite
brosse ici tu pouvoir venir nettoyer mon
petit robot nettoyer tout c'est vraiment
très pratique et comme tous les romans
et balaye et tourne et l'aspirine et toi
ça c'est bien et en plus de ça il peut
même venir un nettoyez vous avez un
petit bac dans lequel vous mettez de
l'eau titre serpillière il fascine et
toi ça brille et ça c'est vraiment pas
titre
[Musique]
mais ça ne s'arrête pas là parce que
vous avez une application qui est
vachement bien fait que vous connaissez
peut-être déjà si vous êtes client de
chimie parce que oui robot rock fait
partie de l'écosystème chez au michelin
8 au capital de robot rock et propose
ses produits en marque propre
les produits robot rock mais par contre
le produit robot rock sont intégrés dans
l'application xiaomi hommes et cette
application est vraiment génial j'ai mon
petit robot ici - 6 alors aujourd'hui il
a strictement rien nettoyer j'ai une
batterie 100%
enfin je vais faire nettoyer vite fait
un mètre carré si je veux vraiment voir
tout ce que j'ai fait je vais cliquez
ici j'ai accès à mon historique de
nettoyage par exemple je retrouve avec
un de mes derniers nettoyage surface
totale 73 m² total 94 minutes et la
voyez les plans complets de ma maison
qui était fait
et franchement bien on plaint joeri des
traits blancs c'est partout là où il est
passé il a fait un tour complet dans la
baraque et ça vous voyez exactement
partout où il est passé les zones qui
n'a pas nettoyé
parce que les obstacles devant qu'il n'a
pas pu y accéder mais voyez franchement
c'est vraiment très très très précis du
coup moi je retrouve avec ça ça c'est le
plein de ma baraque j'ai toutes mes
pièces sans faire de différentes
couleurs je peux venir le lien maintien
qui va lui faire une pièce plutôt qu'une
autre pari si tu préfères le bureau la
chambre d'elliot tu peux aller faire ma
chambre
ou alors si je veux qu'il fasse juste
salon cuisine et bien faire que ça aussi
je dis maintien fait juste l'entrée
parce que je remercie quelque chose
il ira faire uniquement l'entrée ce que
je fais c'est que je sélectionne la
pièce je clique sur nettoyer et il ira
donc ça c'est vachement bien donc ça
c'est la sélection par pièce ensuite je
peux dire ma tu ne fais tout tu vas tout
nettoyer je clique sur nettoyer et là il
est parti ou alors je peux dire par zone
et la voyez je viens sélectionner une
zone via par exemple tiens tu vas me
faire que ce petit carré la up
je choisis ma zone je l'a défini et je
clique sur nettoyer et partir à me faire
la zone donc je veux complètement vire
sélectionné ce que je veux qu'il aille
nettoyer zone par zone pièce par pièce
c'est pratique c'est bien et en plus
c'est lui qui reconnaît les pièces tout
seul c'est pas moi qui lui a dit tiens
ça c'est une pièce c'est une pièce non
il a reconnu qu'ils avaient des murs qui
a une ouverture pas c'est une pièce et
oui il est intelligent plus de ça donc
ils vous choisi vos pièces il vous
sélectionnez vos pièces et vous ensuite
vous attribuer là où vous voulez qu'il
aille mais si vous voulez pas qu'ils
aillent dans certains endroits par
exemple dans une pièce vous avez chez
pas moi comme moi un enfant par exemple
vous avez une zone où il a joué et bien
vous venez mettre des
ur virtuel comme ça il n'ira pas là et
ça aussi c'est vachement bien et c'est
très sécurisé là par exemple j'ai dit à
l'aspirateur devenir aspirer ici la zone
d'entrée mais j'ai exclu la zone il y
avait les chaussures centre et moi parce
que je veux pas qu'ils viennent aspirer
les chaussures jeu qui les laisse
tranquilles et qui lie pas les abîmer
donc là il va venir tout aspiré mais par
contre il va venir contourner la zone
qui est interdite à savoir la zone où il
ya les chaussures et il va faire tout le
reste de la pièce je peux aussi donner
par exemple une bande de délimitation je
veux lui dire maintien qui valait tout
nettoyer sauf cette partie là dans la
cuisine où je ne veux pas que tu ailles
parce que je suis en train de cuisiner
je pouvais être embêté ou quoi que ce
soit donc je peux venir lui délimiter
des zones où je pas qu'il aille des
endroits où dort en espèce de mur
virtuel où il pourra pas aller ensuite
je viens d'enregistrer comme ça je fais
ce que je veux et je peux vraiment venir
paramétrer complètement les zones dans
kg qui viennent nettoyer ma maison
[Musique]
et
moi j'ai un appart donc j'ai pas
d'escalier mais si vous avez les
escaliers chez vous si vous avez une
maison et que vous avez peur qui tombe
dans l'escalier soyez rassurés il est
intelligent il a pas le capteur ce qui
fait qu'ils varient d'abord coup de
poing ils partent côté ils partent côté
et donc il n'a pas du tout de tomber
il est absolument aucun risque et même
si vous avez une maison avec un petit
niveau où une marche
vous êtes tranquille il n'y aura pas
tombé tard cause ce sera à vous de le
prendre et de l'emmener plus bas si vous
voulez tout pas sa deuxième donne au
moins une petite robe ça c'est à vous de
voir bonjour voici venir choisir le team
d'aspiration vous voulez silencieux
équilibré turbo max en fonction de la
zone que vous allez faire et en fonction
du moment de la journée si par exemple
vous lancez l'aspirateur et puis encore
du monde qui dort vous le mettez en
silencieux
ça marchera bien c'est relativement cool
et pratique vous aussi avoir un
démarrage retardé pour venir paramétré
par exemple le moment où vous l'équipe
art vous voulez qu'ils commencent à
aspirer à telle heure pour répéter tous
les jours si vous le souhaitez tous les
jours toutes les semaines vous
définissez complètement vos paramètres
de nettoyage mode de nettoyage équilibré
turbo max vous faites ce que vous voulez
plus par exemple qu'il aspire le lundi
matin ensuite le jeudi matin
vous pouvez le faire pour lequel vous
aussi paramétrer un autre mode aux
heures à laquelle vous serez pas la
partie faire des courses du sport du
loisir ce que vous voulez le type de
vote que vous voulez et ça c'est
vraiment très très très pratique
et puis doigt les paramètres de
l'aspirateur est aussi un mode qui quand
même relativement pas mal c'est ce mode
là le mode npd ne pas déranger
vous choisissez le créneau horaire
auquel vous ne voulez pas qu'ils
puissent partir qu'il ne vous dérange
pas dans les paramètres de l'aspirateur
vous avez aussi un mode moquette que
vous pouvez venir activé si vous avez
une moquette vous passez sur un tapis ça
va amplifier le nettoyage à ses croûtes
mais là vous avez un mode entretien qui
vous dira où est-ce que vous en êtes au
niveau de vos filtres ce qui va falloir
changer bientôt tout ça tout ça
enfin truc est vachement bien voir par
exemple jamais capteurs falloir nettoyer
dans 27 eur ma brosse principal dans 297
art un voyage est quand même
relativement le temps et c'est quand
même cool d'avoir toute petite
information là moi qui sait quelqu'un
qui travaille beaucoup je déteste
complètement perdre du temps avec le
ménage pour tout vous dire que je
déteste ça mais d'un autre côté je n'ai
pas non plus vivre dans des
environnements salle donc le fait
d'avoir des aspirateurs comme le robot
rock assiste pas vraiment venir vous
solutionner la vie j'aimais déjà
beaucoup le s5 je trouvais qu'il y avait
plein de bonnes fonctionnalités qu'elle
est vraiment dans le bon sens le ciss va
encore plus loin
plus rapide plus silencieux le fait de
pouvoir venir choisir les pièces dans
lequel vous allez envoyer l'aspirateur
pour faire du ménage ça vraiment
pratique vraiment simple vraiment bien
est vraiment vraiment vraiment cool et
j'aime beaucoup cette solution là parce
que c'est un vrai gain de temps dans la
vie de tous les jours je sais pas vous
si vous utilisez des aspirateurs robots
si vous trouvez ça intéressant oui donc
quoi comment pouvait marquer tout ça en
bas et s'il vous intéresse il est en pré
commande au tarif de 599 euros avec 99
centimes vous avez le lien en bas dans
la description des postes que vous en
pensez mais en tout cas je de retourner
travailler puisque j'ai pas besoin
d'aller fermer donc ça c'est plutôt cool
merci a bientot hung robeco ciao